Markus: Guten Morgen allerseits. Ähm, können wir anfangen? Ist jeder da?
[Gemurmel im Hintergrund, Stühle werden gerückt]
Sabine: Moment noch, ich suche gerade meine Unterlagen. Hat jemand einen Stift?
Thomas: Hier, ich hab einen. Markus, können wir kurz warten? Ich hole mir noch einen Kaffee.
Markus: [seufzt] Okay, aber bitte schnell. Wir haben heute viel zu besprechen.
[Pause, Geräusche von Papierrascheln und Kaffeetasse]
Markus: Also gut, fangen wir an. Wie ihr wisst, geht es heute um das neue Cover-Material für unsere Türgriffabdeckungen. Hat jemand die Testergebnisse?
Julia: Ja, ich habe sie hier. Moment... [Blättern von Papier] Also, wir haben drei verschiedene Materialien getestet: Polypropylen, ABS und ein neues Biokomposit.
Thomas: [unterbricht] Entschuldigung, ich bin gerade erst reingekommen. Worum geht's nochmal genau?
Markus: [genervt] Thomas, wir sprechen über die neuen Materialien für die Türgriffabdeckungen. Das hatten wir doch letzte Woche schon besprochen.
Thomas: Ah ja, stimmt. Sorry, ich war letzte Woche im Urlaub. Kannst du mich kurz auf den neuesten Stand bringen?
Markus: [seufzt] Also gut. Wir suchen ein neues Material, das umweltfreundlicher ist, aber trotzdem unseren Qualitätsstandards entspricht. Julia war gerade dabei, uns die Testergebnisse zu präsentieren.
Julia: Genau. Wie gesagt, wir haben drei Materialien getestet. Das Polypropylen hat in den Belastungstests gut abgeschnitten, ist aber nicht so umweltfreundlich wie erhofft.
Sabine: Moment mal, ich dachte, wir wollten uns auf nachhaltige Materialien konzentrieren? Warum haben wir dann überhaupt Polypropylen getestet?
Julia: Das war als Vergleichsbasis gedacht. Um zu sehen, wie die anderen Materialien im Verhältnis abschneiden.
Thomas: Macht Sinn. Und wie sieht's mit dem ABS aus? Das haben wir doch schon bei anderen Produkten verwendet, oder?
Julia: Richtig. ABS hat ähnlich gute Eigenschaften wie Polypropylen, ist aber etwas teurer in der Herstellung. Es lässt sich allerdings besser recyceln, was ein Pluspunkt in Sachen Nachhaltigkeit ist.
Markus: Okay, und was ist mit diesem Biokomposit? Davon höre ich zum ersten Mal.
Julia: Das Biokomposit ist wirklich interessant. Es besteht zu 70% aus nachwachsenden Rohstoffen, hauptsächlich Holzfasern und Biopolymere. Die ersten Tests sehen vielversprechend aus.
Sabine: Klingt gut! Aber wie sieht's mit der Haltbarkeit aus? Unsere Kunden erwarten, dass die Abdeckungen mindestens 10 Jahre halten.
Julia: Das ist tatsächlich noch ein Knackpunkt. In den Langzeittests hat das Biokomposit nach etwa 7 Jahren erste Ermüdungserscheinungen gezeigt. Aber wir arbeiten daran, die Zusammensetzung zu optimieren.
Thomas: Moment mal, 7 Jahre? Das ist ja gar nicht so schlecht. Vielleicht können wir das als Feature verkaufen? Sowas wie "Nach 7 Jahren ist es Zeit für ein Upgrade!"
Markus: [skeptisch] Ich weiß nicht, ob unsere Kunden das so sehen würden. Die erwarten Qualität und Langlebigkeit von uns.
Sabine: Ich sehe da auch ein Problem mit unserem Markenimage. Wir werben doch immer mit der Langlebigkeit unserer Produkte.
Julia: Das stimmt. Aber vielleicht können wir einen Mittelweg finden? Zum Beispiel könnten wir das Biokomposit für eine neue, umweltfreundliche Produktlinie verwenden und parallel dazu unsere klassischen Produkte weiterführen?
Markus: Hmm, das ist eine Überlegung wert. Wie sieht's denn mit den Kosten aus? Können wir das Biokomposit zu einem wettbewerbsfähigen Preis anbieten?
Julia: Die Materialkosten sind derzeit noch etwa 15% höher als bei ABS. Aber wenn wir die Produktion hochfahren, könnte sich das ändern. Außerdem könnten wir eventuell Fördermittel für nachhaltige Innovationen beantragen.
Thomas: Oh, das erinnert mich an etwas! Ich habe neulich einen Artikel über Förderprogramme für grüne Technologien gelesen. Soll ich das mal recherchieren?
Markus: Ja, das wäre gut. Kannst du bis nächste Woche eine Übersicht zusammenstellen?
Thomas: Klar, mache ich. Ähm, wo war der Artikel nochmal... [kramt in seinen Unterlagen]
Sabine: Können wir nochmal zurück zu den Testergebnissen kommen? Julia, wie sieht es mit der Farbstabilität des Biokomposits aus?
Julia: Guter Punkt, Sabine. Die Farbstabilität ist tatsächlich eine Herausforderung. Das Material neigt dazu, unter UV-Einstrahlung etwas auszubleichen. Wir experimentieren gerade mit verschiedenen UV-Stabilisatoren.
Markus: Das klingt nach einer Menge Arbeit. Wie lange, schätzt du, brauchen wir noch, bis wir ein marktreifes Produkt haben?
Julia: Wenn alles gut läuft, könnten wir in etwa 6 Monaten so weit sein. Aber das ist optimistisch. Realistisch betrachtet sollten wir mit 9 bis 12 Monaten rechnen.
Thomas: [unterbricht] Tut mir leid, ich muss kurz telefonieren. Meine Frau ruft an. [steht auf und verlässt den Raum]
Markus: [seufzt] Okay, machen wir ohne ihn weiter. Sabine, was denkst du? Sollen wir das Biokomposit weiter verfolgen oder uns auf die Verbesserung von ABS konzentrieren?
Sabine: Ich denke, wir sollten beides im Auge behalten. Das Biokomposit hat großes Potenzial, gerade im Hinblick auf unsere Nachhaltigkeitsziele. Aber ABS ist eine sichere Bank. Vielleicht können wir die Ressourcen aufteilen?
Julia: Das sehe ich ähnlich. Wir könnten ein Team auf die Optimierung des Biokomposits ansetzen und ein anderes auf die Verbesserung unserer ABS-Formulierung. So haben wir am Ende vielleicht sogar zwei neue Produktlinien.
Markus: Klingt vernünftig. Aber wir müssen die Kosten im Auge behalten. Julia, kannst du bis zum nächsten Meeting eine detaillierte Kostenaufstellung für beide Szenarien machen?
Julia: Natürlich, ich setze mich mit der Finanzabteilung zusammen und bereite das vor.
[Thomas kommt zurück in den Raum]
Thomas: Sorry für die Unterbrechung. Hab ich was Wichtiges verpasst?
Markus: [leicht genervt] Wir haben gerade beschlossen, sowohl das Biokomposit als auch ABS weiterzuverfolgen. Julia wird eine Kostenaufstellung vorbereiten. Apropos, Thomas, vergiss nicht die Recherche zu den Förderprogrammen.
Thomas: Ach ja, stimmt. Mach ich. Ähm, hat jemand einen Notizzettel für mich? Ich finde meinen Block gerade nicht.
Sabine: [reicht ihm einen Zettel] Hier. Übrigens, sollten wir nicht auch über mögliche Lieferanten für das Biokomposit sprechen? Ich habe gehört, dass die Verfügbarkeit manchmal problematisch sein kann.
Markus: Guter Punkt, Sabine. Julia, kannst du das bitte auch in deine Recherche mit aufnehmen? Wir brauchen eine Übersicht über potenzielle Lieferanten, ihre Kapazitäten und Preise.
Julia: Klar, mache ich. Ich habe schon ein paar Kontakte aus einem Branchentreffen letzten Monat. Ich werde die mal anrufen und mehr Informationen einholen.
Thomas: Oh, apropos Branchentreffen. Nächsten Monat ist doch diese große Messe in Frankfurt. Sollten wir da nicht hingehen? Vielleicht gibt's da neue Entwicklungen zu sehen.
Markus: Stimmt, die hatte ich fast vergessen. Gut, dass du das erwähnst, Thomas. Ja, ich denke, wir sollten ein Team hinschicken. Julia, kannst du das organisieren? Nimm am besten noch jemanden aus dem Vertrieb mit.
Julia: Alles klar, ich kümmere mich darum. Soll ich auch einen Stand für uns buchen oder gehen wir nur als Besucher?
Markus: Hmm, gute Frage. Was meint ihr? Ein Stand wäre eine Möglichkeit, unsere neuen Entwicklungen zu präsentieren, aber es ist auch mit viel Aufwand verbunden.
Sabine: Ich denke, wir sollten dieses Mal nur als Besucher gehen. Wir sind mit unseren neuen Materialien noch nicht so weit, dass wir sie präsentieren könnten. Aber wir könnten die Messe nutzen, um Kontakte zu knüpfen und die Konkurrenz im Auge zu behalten.
Thomas: Ja, sehe ich auch so. Außerdem können wir uns dann freier bewegen und mehr sehen, als wenn wir an einen Stand gebunden wären.
Markus: Okay, dann machen wir das so. Julia, organisiere bitte die Reise für ein kleines Team. Und bereite ein Briefing vor, worauf wir besonders achten sollten. Vielleicht finden wir ja noch weitere interessante Materialien oder Technologien.
Julia: Verstanden. Ich erstelle eine Liste mit den wichtigsten Ausstellern und Vorträgen, die für uns relevant sein könnten.
Sabine: Apropos relevante Aussteller, hat jemand schon mal was von der Firma Bio-Tech-Polymere gehört? Die sollen angeblich auch an nachhaltigen Kunststoffen arbeiten.
Julia: Bio-Tech-Polymere? Der Name klingt mir nicht bekannt. Aber ich kann sie auf jeden Fall mit auf die Liste setzen und recherchieren.
Thomas: Oh, ich glaube, ich habe mal einen Artikel über sie gelesen. Die arbeiten doch mit irgendwelchen Algen, oder?
Markus: Algen? Das klingt interessant. Kinder wir sollten das definitiv im Auge behalten. [Transkriptionsfehler: "Kinder" statt "Klingt"]
Sabine: Ja, genau! Ich erinnere mich jetzt auch. Die verwenden Algen als Grundstoff für ihre Polymere. Das könnte vielleicht auch für uns interessant sein.
Julia: Algen-basierte Polymere? Das ist ja spannend. Ich werde das auf jeden Fall genauer untersuchen. Vielleicht können wir auf der Messe mehr darüber erfahren.
Markus: Gut, dann halten wir das fest. Julia, nimm das bitte mit in deine Recherche auf. Gibt es noch weitere Punkte, die wir besprechen sollten?
Thomas: Äh, ja, ich hätte da noch was. [Pause] Moment, ich hab's gleich... [Papierrascheln]
Markus: [seufzt] Thomas, wenn du es nicht findest, können wir vielleicht erstmal weitermachen? Wir haben noch einige Punkte auf der Agenda.
Thomas: Ja, sorry. Es war irgendwas mit... ach ja! Produktionskapazitäten! Wenn wir neue Materialien einführen, müssen wir vielleicht unsere Produktionslinien anpassen, oder?
Julia: Guter Punkt, Thomas. Das hängt natürlich von den spezifischen Eigenschaften der neuen Materialien ab. Aber ja, wir müssen das definitiv berücksichtigen.
Sabine: Stimmt, das könnte teuer werden. Haben wir dafür überhaupt Budget? [Hintergrundgeräusch: Türknarren]
Markus: Das müssen wir mit der Finanzabteilung besprechen. Julia, kannst du das bitte auch in deine Kostenaufstellung aufnehmen?
Julia: Natürlich, ich werde das berücksichtigen. Ich setze mich am besten auch mit der Produktionsleitung zusammen, um die möglichen Auswirkungen zu besprechen.
Thomas: Oh, und was ist mit den Zulieferern? Müssen die nicht auch ihre Prozesse anpassen, wenn wir neue Materialien verwenden?
Sabine: Guter Punkt, Thomas. Das könnte unsere Lieferkette beeinflussen. Wir sollten vielleicht auch mit unseren wichtigsten Zulieferern sprechen.
Markus: Ja, das ist wichtig. Julia, kannst du das bitte auch notieren? Wir sollten einen Plan entwickeln, wie wir unsere Zulieferer einbeziehen können.
Julia: Verstanden. Ich werde einen Entwurf für einen Kommunikationsplan erstellen. Soll ich dabei auch gleich Terminvorschläge für Gespräche mit den wichtigsten Zulieferern machen?
Markus: Ja, das wäre gut. Aber lass uns erst die internen Entscheidungen treffen, bevor wir nach außen gehen.
Thomas: Äh, Moment mal. Sollten wir nicht auch die Marketingabteilung einbeziehen? Ich meine, wenn wir neue, umweltfreundliche Materialien verwenden, ist das doch ein guter Verkaufspunkt, oder?
Sabine: Stimmt, guter Gedanke. Vielleicht können wir damit auch neue Kundengruppen erreichen.
Markus: Ja, das macht Sinn. Julia, kannst du bitte auch einen Termin mit dem Marketingteam vereinbaren? Wir sollten ihre Ideen dazu hören.
Julia: Alles klar, ich kümmere mich darum. Soll ich versuchen, das noch diese Woche zu organisieren?
Markus: Wenn möglich, ja. Je früher wir alle ins Boot holen, desto besser. [Hintergrundgeräusch: Handyklingeln]
Thomas: Oh, Entschuldigung, das ist meins. [Pause] Ähm, ich muss kurz rangehen. Ist wichtig.
Markus: [genervt] Schon wieder? Okay, aber bitte schnell. Wir sind hier noch nicht fertig.
[Thomas verlässt den Raum]
Sabine: Während Thomas weg ist, können wir vielleicht über die Zeitplanung sprechen? Wie realistisch sind die 9 bis 12 Monate, die Julia erwähnt hat?
Julia: Das ist natürlich eine grobe Schätzung. Es hängt davon ab, wie schnell wir die Materialtests abschließen können und wie die Ergebnisse ausfallen.
Markus: Verstehe. Können wir den Prozess irgendwie beschleunigen? Vielleicht durch Parallelisierung einiger Schritte?
Julia: Möglicherweise. Ich könnte einen detaillierten Zeitplan erstellen und sehen, wo wir Optimierungspotenzial haben. Aber wir sollten vorsichtig sein, Qualität geht vor Geschwindigkeit.
Sabine: Ja, auf keinen Fall dürfen wir die Qualität vernachlässigen. Unsere Kunden erwarten Spitzenprodukte von uns.
Markus: Richtig. Also, Julia, bitte erstelle einen detaillierten Zeitplan, aber berücksichtige dabei, dass wir keine Kompromisse bei der Qualität eingehen.
Julia: Verstanden. Ich werde verschiedene Szenarien durchspielen und Ihnen die Optionen vorstellen.
[Thomas kommt zurück]
Thomas: So, bin wieder da. Was hab ich verpasst?
Markus: Wir haben über den Zeitplan gesprochen. Julia wird verschiedene Szenarien ausarbeiten. [Transkriptionsfehler: "Zeitplan" als "Zeilplan" erkannt]
Thomas: Oh, okay. Ähm, wo waren wir nochmal vor meinem Anruf?
Sabine: [leicht genervt] Wir sprachen über die Einbeziehung des Marketingteams, Thomas.
Thomas: Ah ja, stimmt! Hatte ich da nicht noch was zu Kundenumfragen gesagt?
Markus: Nein, das hattest du nicht erwähnt. Aber jetzt, wo du es sagst - das wäre tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Julia: Kundenumfragen? Ja, das könnte hilfreich sein. Wir könnten herausfinden, wie wichtig Nachhaltigkeit für unsere Kunden tatsächlich ist.
Sabine: Guter Punkt. Vielleicht können wir das mit dem Marketing zusammen planen? Die haben doch Erfahrung mit solchen Umfragen.
Markus: Ja, das macht Sinn. Julia, kannst du das bitte auch auf die Liste setzen? Wir sollten das beim Meeting mit dem Marketing ansprechen.
Julia: Notiert. Ich werde es in die Agenda für das Marketing-Meeting aufnehmen.
Thomas: Super! Und, ähm, was ist mit den Kosten für die Umfrage? Haben wir dafür Budget?
Markus: [seufzt] Das müssen wir noch klären. Julia, kannst du bitte auch eine grobe Kostenschätzung für die Kundenumfrage machen?
Julia: Natürlich, ich werde das in die Gesamtkostenaufstellung mit aufnehmen.
Sabine: Moment mal, sollten wir nicht auch unsere internationalen Märkte berücksichtigen? Die Präferenzen könnten je nach Land unterschiedlich sein.
Markus: Guter Punkt, Sabine. Das verkompliziert die Sache natürlich, aber du hast Recht, wir sollten das nicht außer Acht lassen.
Julia: Okay, ich werde das in die Planung mit einbeziehen. Vielleicht können wir zunächst mit unseren Hauptmärkten beginnen und dann schrittweise erweitern?
Markus: Ja, das klingt vernünftig. Lasst uns so vorgehen. Gibt es noch weitere Punkte, die wir besprechen sollten?
Thomas: Oh, mir fällt gerade ein... [Transkriptionsfehler: unverständlich]
Markus: Was sagtest du, Thomas? Das Transkript hat dich nicht verstanden.
Thomas: Oh, sorry. Ich meinte, wir sollten vielleicht auch über mögliche Patente nachdenken. Wenn wir neue Materialien entwickeln, könnten die ja patentierbar sein.
Sabine: Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt! Wir sollten auf jeden Fall unsere Rechtsabteilung einbeziehen.
Markus: Absolut. Julia, kannst du bitte auch einen Termin mit der Rechtsabteilung vereinbaren? Wir sollten frühzeitig über mögliche Patentanmeldungen sprechen.
Julia: Verstanden. Ich werde das in die To-Do-Liste aufnehmen und einen Termin organisieren.
Markus: Gut, ich denke, damit haben wir die wichtigsten Punkte abgedeckt. Lasst uns zum Abschluss noch einmal die nächsten Schritte zusammenfassen.
Julia: Alles klar. Also, ich werde: 1. Eine detaillierte Kostenaufstellung vorbereiten, 2. Einen Zeitplan mit verschiedenen Szenarien erstellen, 3. Ein Meeting mit dem Marketing-Team organisieren...
Sabine: [unterbricht] Entschuldigung, aber sollten wir nicht auch einen Projektmanager für all das benennen? Das scheint mir zu viel für eine Person zu sein.
Markus: Du hast Recht, Sabine. Das ist eine Menge Arbeit. Julia, wärest du bereit, die Projektleitung zu übernehmen? Du scheinst am tiefsten in der Materie zu stecken.
Julia: Ähm, ja, ich denke schon. Aber ich würde gerne ein kleines Team zusammenstellen, um die Aufgaben zu verteilen. Ist